SHIGERU MIYAGAWA: When
you look at what's
happening in the
world now, you see
that institutions like MIT,
Harvard, Stanford, Berkeley,
they are all producing
digital content
and sharing it with the world.
That's something that we
started with OpenCourseWare
here at MIT in the year 2001.
This is now part of the
profile of a top university.
You do research.
You teach your students.
And you share your
material with the world.
What I see also happening
now is that not only
do you share your digital
educational content
with the world, but you
bring it back on campus
and use that digital
content to transform
your own residential classroom.
This is sort of the final
piece of the loop, which
I think MIT is very
serious in accomplishing.
We have produced
something like 200 MOOCs.
And they are all used.
Virtually all of them are being
used for residential education,
so much so that 90% of
undergraduate students
take at least one course
at MIT that uses the MOOC.
Open Courseware is used widely
by undergraduate students,
more so than most
people realize.
I don't think I've ever run
across an MIT undergraduate
student who had not
heard of Open Courseware.
They use it sort of like air.
They use it to see
if they want to take
a certain course next semester.
They use that to catch
up on their own course.
They use problem sets
from several years
ago just to brush up on
their own study of the course
that they're taking
and sometimes
just to look at a course they
know they're not going to take,
because it's outside
of their specialty,
but they're just
curious about what's
being taught in that course.